how do you create a part of a person
that feels like it is a part of them so
that they can not just like get by but
so they can express their self with the
limb that they have they can feel good
about it they can feel sexy inspired and
most importantly shows that having a
little difference is not something that
necessarily stops you my name is seth
cane also known as dr. adventure and i'm
the founder and CEO of the new flesh
workshop but most of my friends call me
doc just to clarify you're not actually
a doctor i am not actually a physician
or a PhD the new flesh workshop is
something i started in 2007 just in my
mom's garage what we do is develop
various types of prosthetic add-ons and
customizations biomedical implant
devices and various types of wearable
technologies for human enhancement
there's been several firsts that have
come out of the new flesh workshop as
far as I know were the first you know
company to make ballistic casemod for a
prosthetic leg that's a cool piece we
can make a prosthetic that'll stop 9
millimeter rounds we've created for you
know couple under dollars a DIY solution
for missing your ear on the outside and
still being able to hear without having
to go through like multiple major
surgeries and having holes drilled in
your skull
do I consider myself a mad scientist I
consider myself a fairly happy scientist
actually a lot of my inspiration comes
from stories comic books and sci-fi and
the writers of these kinds of stories
are always looking at what could happen
next but they don't know how to do it
but I think at some point somebody is
like no no I'm gonna like Jules Verne
was right I'm gonna build a submarine
like somebody's got to do that and that
that is probably the thing that really
gets me up in the morning with a smile
on to go and make something happen